nobody blanks with a Biden looks like
Eric Adams had to learn that lesson the
hard way heady President Biden's dumping
the New York mayor as a surrogate for
his 2024 campaign after Adams dared to
criticize him over the Border crisis
there's a crisis right now and that
crisis should be coordinated by the
national government we are speaking
directly to the Biden's Administration
the national government has turned his
back on New York City this is in the lap
of the president of the United States
it's the irresponsibility of the White
House for not addressing this problem
team Biden punishing Adams by yanking
his name off of an Advisory Board and a
Democrat Aid squealing that quote the
relationship is soured between the two
liberal Titans because the mayor had
made somewhere between in Artful to
stupid comments that were kind of out of
bounds
interesting that Biden's booting a
prominent black Democrat while his
administration goes hardcore on
diversity but Adams might consider
himself lucky that he got to dodge
having to be in a lame Biden campaign at
I'm on team Biden Harris I'm on team
Biden Harris Joe Biden rocks re-electing
President Biden is a bft Joe Biden oh
he's ready
all right so do you think Adams may have
dodged a bullet Jessica now he doesn't
have to go out there and you know be so
political he can work for the city
no I every politician I guess once you
become president it stops but they want
the next thing right they're never
actually content with whatever it is
that they're doing they've just found
out that they can't get a better job so
then they say look I'm here working for
you so no I don't think it's net net a
good thing for mayor Adams I think it's
a mistake on the part of the
administration I think that you should
have as many diverse voices and I'm not
just talking about the color of his skin
but the tone of his message represented
I mean he has Eric Adams has exactly the
same message as Keisha Lance bottoms who
then went on to join the administration
when she declined to run again to be
mayor of Atlanta if you listen to her
during the summer of 2020 it sounds just
like Eric Adams like this is
inappropriate this is like this is
looting this isn't about peaceful
protests Etc
um and New York City matters it's one of
the most important cities in the country
you should want the mayor of this city
on your task force they used to call
Trump Petty judge
you know the amazing part of it is I
mean it's just so consistent with this
totalitarian Instinct that they have you
talk the way we talk you say what we
want you to say or we're going to cut
you off you don't deserve to be heard
and so you know he's getting kicked to
the curb yeah but the truth is that
um Adams is Right unfortunately he is
right but but there's also another piece
to it and that is that New York is a
sanctuary City and it just goes to show
you how they're all talk until you put
the pedal to the metal you know they
talk to talk but when it comes to
walking the walk the Democrat can't do
it and so now he's trying to send him to
Rockland Rockland got a restraining
order and apparently now they're trying
to send and they're bringing out the
state police I mean there's so much
going on you know everybody's running
the court to try and kind of change the
then the Biden administration had two
years to prepare for this thing you know
and now everybody's running to court to
try to get in order to overturn his
order to not let them into my accounting
no send them back to your this is lunacy
does this send a broader message to all
the Democrats I was just taking all over
the country I do think this is a great
thing for Eric Adams if he wants to
actually if he does have aspirations for
higher office this gives him a great
path to be a more independent person I'd
be like thank you I don't have to go to
that meeting perfect I'll free up on my
schedule so that I can go actually hand
out fruit to migrants so he's sitting
here telling the mayor the mayor any
mayor of his a city they're on the more
on the front lines than any president
will ever be they actually have to look
their constituents in the face they see
them on the streets of work President
Biden's at the White House you don't see
anybody so mayor Adams is saying no
actually I need help here but he's not
the only one wait till Governor polis so
Colorado starts saying more Mary
Lightfoot well she's leaving but the new
guy Brandon is that his name Brandon
yeah brand something Johnson thank you
whatever his name is oh I'll get your
name when you get uh confirmed when you
get sworn in but I do think that this is
going to Cascade because it's not going
to be just New York City you see what's
happening in Denver Colorado it is a
ferocious they're thinking of putting
homeless camps and micro camps all over
the city and because they don't have
enough shelter space right it's not
going to be just the Border towns it's
everywhere so if I were Eric Adams I
would say excellent thank you I'm glad
my schedule just freed up Greg you know
if Joe was an old white Republican he
would be called racist
that's all I got no this is a feather
this is a feather in the mayor's cap you
know when Joe Biden doesn't want to work
with you that's like Alec Baldwin not
wanting to direct you in a western
you dodged a bullet figuratively uh
someone should ask Joe if he thinks
mayor Adams is black no you probably
wouldn't get the joke because he
wouldn't remember it because he doesn't
even remember the name of the Visiting
Angel who gave him his Maalox but this
is at this countdown this countdown to
is is it to the end of title 42. it
feels like New Year's Eve for rich white
liberals who need their Hedges trimmed
and their leaves blown
they have no more openings in the
Landscaping industry I've talked to a
bunch of contractors they are full
really yes uh what are you going to do
this summer yeah Jesse
I cut a nice lawn hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else